[Music]
foreign
[Music]
personality but apparently within the
Chinese Communist party it's not there
are no Xi Jinping badges yet I wrote my
Master's thesis on mountain dog badges
there are a lot of memes though I I
don't know the modern day equivalent are
like it's not good hello and welcome to
Chinese Whispers with me Cindy you every
episode I'll be talking to journalist
experts and long time China Watchers
about the latest in Chinese politics
society and more there'll be a
smattering of History to catch you up on
the background knowledge and some
context as well how did the Chinese see
these issues every five years Beijing
goes into heightened security as senior
members of the Chinese Communist Party
gather the National Party Congress is an
occasion for the party to review his
track record and determine its future
Direction but most crucially it's a
moment to unveil Future Leaders
older members of the seven member
Pollock Bureau standing committee are
retired while fresh blood is brought in
including at the very top the general
secretary under a norm set down by Den
Xiaoping this General Secretary is meant
to be changed to every other Congress in
other words every 10 years but at this
upcoming Congress most China Watchers
expect Xi Jinping to remain in position
beginning his third term in power and
he'll try to pack the signing committee
with his own allies so to look ahead to
this important event in the Communist
calendar with me today are two
distinguished including guests
but before I introduce them I also just
want to do a little housekeeping if you
enjoy what we do here at Chinese
Whispers then you might also enjoy an
upcoming Chinese Whispers newsletter
it'll be written by me and it'll be
everything you love about the podcast
rounding up the latest cultural and
political headlines from China with of
course a smattering of History if you'd
like to sign up for it for free go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash Whispers
now then my guests today are Bill Bishop
and Professor Victor she Bill runs the
Fantastic cynicism newsletter a regular
Roundup of the must-know political and
economic news from China with a close
eye on development within the party and
Victor is an expert in Chinese Elite
politics his latest book is coalitions
of the week which looks at how marsadong
in many ways sees role model
successfully routed his competitors to
establish his own one-man rule Bill
Bishop and Victor she welcome to Chinese
Whispers
um bill can we start by explaining what
the National Party Congress is and what
it does
um hi welcome thank you for having me
again it's a real pleasure to be back on
I love your podcast uh so the so the the
National Party Congress is the most
important
um sort of meeting for the Communist
party it's now held every five years and
it consists of a group of I think around
2200 delegates or was that the number
they just came out with yeah and they
then
um they set the broad agenda they select
the Central Committee then the Central
Committee out of that comes the Power
Bureau and then the standing committee
and then the standing committee and the
popular sort of run the party on a on a
sort of a more regularized basis and so
um you have the the party Congress will
meet sort of they'll have a this will be
the 20th party Congress
um and then sort of every year for the
next five years you'll have one
um one plenum or so which is um uh but
but this is really the this is The Big
Show for the Chinese Communist party
where
um if inside the party basically Nothing
Else Matters every five years and and in
those interim period as you're sort of
trying to set the agenda and pick the
next leaders and pick your supporters
um and Victor Bill said that this was a
big show um so I guess that's the
question for Outsiders whenever the
Communist party has this kind of
um Grand meetings how much is it a show
and the big decisions have already been
made behind the back behind the scenes
and in which case what is the point of
them what is the purpose of them um or
is there something more uh more
important going on actually
well I it's uh there are a lot of shows
that go on uh in the Chinese government
but this is not one of them I I think
this I agree with Bill that this
actually is a very important event
to me it is
um kind of once every five years to
crystallization and formalization of a
lot of informal politics and jogging
behind the scene
at the party Congress you will actually
get to see who is going to get into the
Central Committee who is going to get
into the public Bureau and the public
standing committee on top of that the
policy it also has a very important
policy significance in that the
political work report which Xi Jinping
himself presumably will read out uh for
like three hours straight that actually
is a very important document it sets the
agenda for the next five years it's a
huge laundry list of a lot of different
policy agendas nonetheless if it doesn't
get mentioned in the political work
report it most likely is going to get
neglected you know unless some kind of
external event forces the the regime to
pay attention to it so it is a very
important document
um so it is the formalization of a lot
of jocking and you know we're going to
talk about all the people who may or may
not get into the politburo ETC I'm sorry
if I could just add to that I think
Victor's absolutely right and the
political work report really does
set out the road map in many ways for
the next five years and longer
potentially the other thing though to
your question is is
it's pretty much all set by the time
they announce the dates for the party
Congress right they're not going to show
up and then really I think debate a lot
of these issues that there will have
been the work reports should be
basically done the Personnel selection
should be done they would I think they
usually don't seem to announce the dates
for the party Congress this time they
announced that I believe at the end of
August
um until they have everything locked
down
and and Victor just now you mentioned
the term Central Committee uh product
Bureau public Bureau standing committee
so am I writing thinking the Central
Committee is a few hundred people strong
and then the pilot Bureau is chosen from
that and then public Bureau standing
committee is a seven people within that
so so there's a kind of hierarchy going
on and that's what we mean when we talk
about these terms that they're the kind
of the top levels of the party yeah so
but you know as Bill mentioned kind of
2000 2200 people will show up in Beijing
uh in the middle of October they will
elect so they there's actually a voting
procedure whereby they elect the Central
Committee which is roughly 200 full
members and 150 alternate members Ultra
members will not have voting power in
the subsequent in five years uh but they
can attend all the plenums and if
someone in the Central Committee gets
removed or die then a couple of them can
move up into the Central Committee and
then the Central Committee in turn will
elect the Paula Bureau and the poly
Bureau standing committee as well as to
re-elect Xi Jinping presumably for this
party Secretary General position
so let's talk about Xi Jinping then
um because you know this has been widely
seen at the moment that he would have
stepped down had he been following
convention previously but I think few
people really expect him to and to
understand that continuation of power
and what form it might take can we first
explain the titles that he holds bill
because he is both the president of
China and the General Secretary of the
Chinese Communist party so what do these
respective titles mean because I think
we on the outside often only talk about
him as the president of China well
there's also another title that's very
important which is he's the he's the
chairman of the the central military
Commission of um both the party which
matters more in the state
um but you know the and the president
title really in Chinese it's chairman
but it gets translated in English as
um president even though it really isn't
sort of analogous to say the U.S
president but from a party perspective
um yes you know the the General
Secretary of position is is is the key
um he is the core of the core of the
party but in terms of sort of power
having the um the the chairmanship of
the the CMC the central military
commission is is also very important one
thing we saw in um the early 2000s when
hujin Tom became General secretaries for
several years Zhang Zim and his
predecessor remained as chair of the
central military commission and was
effectively running sort of uh I don't
want to say a shadow government but was
was actually very much overshadowing
who's in town with his power there does
not seem to be uh any real
um doubt that she will get all those
titles if he wants them um there is some
talk about re-adding back a title of
party chairman that Mao Zedong had that
might sort of reshuffle things but
um whatever comes out of it I don't
think we're going to see any sort of
diminution of XI jinping's stature or
power
secretary then
um is it between State and party that
distinction that the president is Head
of the State and the general secretary
is head of the party essentially so one
is a party function one is a state
function that's right and do they get
confirmed at the same time or is it
different parts of the party so only the
party positions will be confirmed at the
20th party Congress
um if he wants it you know as Bill
pointed out um he can get an extension
as the state chairman at the national
people's Congress which will be next
march or so uh well Bill you're
forgetting a possible new title
I don't know if that's going to be the
people's leader people's leader uh you
know of folks fear if you want to say
that in German
um yeah so that's been making the rounds
on the Press uh you know I wonder if
it's going to get formalized that that
would be pretty interesting
what would that mean would that just be
like calling dental pain like Paramount
leader does it have any
um formal role associated with it that
is the question I mean you can write
some things in a party Constitution so
there's been you know all this talk
about revising party Constitution
the the two uh Church uh like the two
confirmation
establishments will be written in we
know that
will something else be written in I mean
so so you know one um
potential development not I don't think
for this party Congress but potentially
five years from now is that
um she will get this very lofty title
which encompasses control over you know
party State military
then he can delegate one of his
positions most likely the Secretary
General position to another person a
potential successor
so this could be setting the stage for
it but you know this is all pure
speculation we don't know of any of
that's going to happen
um I would guess that most people in the
Chinese government would not like to be
that doesn't need a successor because
past designated successors have not met
with a very good end and there you can
read my book actually if you're
interested in that of course it's
basically putting a large Target on your
back and your front right yes but today
that's really interesting to the to the
to the people's leader that um uh sort
of can I don't know if you call it a
title or
um sort of appellation to Xi Jinping
um you know that whether or not it
brings any formal Authority it certainly
brings him sort of if if you think one
of she's goals is to be sort of at or
above multitong and sort of the pantheon
of the Communist Party
um history then you know Mao Zedong was
also a link show right and that's a very
specific term in Chinese got it for a
little while but then he you know he
didn't really matter after a bit
um so this would be another kind of
elevation of Xi Jinping along with for
example if his if the Xi Jinping thought
on socialism with Chinese characters if
a new era becomes a sort of shortened to
just say Xi Jinping thought in the
Constitution those would both be sort of
putting him up at the The Mao Zone level
which I think he does seem to
um want from what we can observe but
taking a step back I want to
disaggregate these titles because I want
to look at the continuation of power of
CEO and what that really means when when
pundits and when China Watchers talk
about that
um because Victors you say he doesn't
presidents get decided at the national
people's Congress each uh in the spring
so this National Party Congress that's
coming up is confirm him as general
secretary again and I think there's a
lot of confusion because what he
abolished in terms of term limits a few
years ago was actually the term limits
to the president not to the general
secretary so he could always have said
on as general secretary so fix it I
think should we should we talk a little
bit about why he wears these three hats
at the moment like what were the
circumstances that meant that he and his
two predecessors were seen as it was a
norm for them to wear Three Hats
uh yeah so this was not always the case
in the 1980s
um you know Deng Xiaoping was the
chairman of the central military
commission but did not serve as
Secretary General did not serve as State
president
um those positions belong to other
people in the 1980s there was power
sharing uh between sort of the the
survivors of the Long March generation
uh again you can read my book about all
about how that came about
um but basically toward the end of the
1980s especially after the trauma of the
tenement Square massacre a new
leadership had to be established the
Long March generation knew that they
were getting old they were going to die
in a few years time so they wanted to
entrust
um whoever the successor is with a lot
of formal power so that at least they
have a chance of hanging on to power if
you divide up the power among you know
very weak very Junior officials they
wouldn't even have a chance of staying
under power
so the person they picked John zameen
was eventually entrusted with all three
positions Secretary General chairman of
the central military commission as well
as State president
um you know after a few months time so
you know done shopping waited like I
forgot two or three months before
stepping down from the CMC chairman
position and handing it over to Jones I
mean uh and after that that became the
norm the other Norm that was established
uh around that time was that whoever is
chosen as the Secretary General would
only serve too full term so that um even
at the
1992 14 party Congress uh it was
understood that hujin Tao would become
the next Secretary General uh in 10
years time in 2002 which he became and
so by serving a third full term
um as Xi Jinping would be violating that
Norm that was set forth I mean granted
it's not a super new Norm uh super old
Norm because it was just established in
the early 1990s but nonetheless uh both
jensamine well gen zamine sort of stuck
to it you know because he tried to State
on for a couple of years as CMC chairman
Tau definitely adhere to it and stepped
down from all of his positions in 2012.
uh Xi Jinping is not going along with it
in the party Constitution there's no
limit to the terms of the Secretary
General and the reason is because the
Chinese Communist party uh was and still
is a revolutionary party and during a
revolution you can't make a lot of rules
for the leadership because anything can
happen uh the kmt can swoop in and
arrest everybody so so you have to
entrust enormous amount of power in the
hands of the Secretary General they
never got around to changing it uh so
even after Chairman Mao and everything
that he did the only thing that they
changed was that oh well a cult of
personality is not a good thing in the
party that is still mentioned in the
party although in the party Constitution
although I don't know what you would
call what's happening today which anyone
would say it's a cult of personality but
apparently within the Chinese Communist
party it's not you know so there are no
there are no Xi Jinping badges yet I
wrote my Master's uh thesis on Mao Zone
badges
um so so we still have the don't have
the C badges yet once we do that it'll
be really there are a lot of memes
though I I don't know the modern day
equivalent are like it's not good
memes you know
yeah
and Bill and Victor as an aside did you
guys see that guy flipping dumplings he
really looked like she's doing things be
making the rounds on doing
foreign
how amazing is that
sorry anyway that's such a decoration
can look like him and they get
highlighted in social media
um Bill let's talk about this October
then how big a moment is it because as
Victor has just outlined it would be
overturning there's relatively new Norm
but still Norm nevertheless that both of
his predecessors roughly stuck too
um and there seemed to be a return of
the cult of personality
on the other hand I guess people always
thought this was going to happen ever
since the time limit abolishment
um last in the last few years so you
know I think
um it is a big deal because it if he
does stay on it it really does represent
a um in some ways I think a real
regression in um what what a lot of
Outsiders a lot of people inside the
comments writer too I think thought was
a progression towards some sort of
institutionalization within the Chinese
Communist party uh you know the it's
interesting when you read sort of the
the various bits that are you know stuff
she's saying the the historical
resolution that was passed last uh last
fall a lot of the propaganda the run-up
to the party Congress you know the
argument really is being made that China
that they're in this very special moment
they're they're as close they're as
closer to this this National
Rejuvenation they've ever been and they
need sort of a strong leader to continue
right and of course that you know this
is all sort of the two establishes plays
into that this idea that the strong
leader the continuity they need Xi
Jinping right so they're very much
laying the groundwork for she to be
basically the the person running the
show for as long as he wants what's
going to be interesting as we get out of
the party Congress in October and we see
who the new leadership is and
specifically who's on the standing
committee and and what the size is
because it's seven but it used to be
nine it has been five I believe at some
point so and again it's not fixed in any
rules it could change
um is to to your point of Victor like
with where hujin Tao was effectively
designated as successor in 1992 for 2002
for 10 years in the future
will we see anybody who shows up in the
leadership lineup in October who looks
like their potential successor and is
that at least 10 years out right because
normally we would be at a point where we
would have had at least one or two terms
of somebody who could credibly replace
or succeed teaching paying say in 2027
we're basically at zero so so so it's
potentially then what at a minimum we're
saying okay 10 more years at a minimum
which would mean she would be 79 which
seems old but to be honest
you know Joe Biden is 79 today
right so so from a sort of a perspective
of a world leader she at 79 I mean
there's no reason he can't keep going
sort of physically and mentally in some
ways I think the Chinese leaders seem to
age better than than the Western leaders
well I mean they better care I think but
in all seriousness we we're gonna there
be lots of things that we're going to
have to pick through coming out of the
20th party Congress both from what's in
the the report but then also really it's
not just like who's Premier it's are
there any credible successors even alive
now and if they're not then we're
looking I think you can really
really credibly push out the timeline
for Xi Jinping to remain in power
right because because 15 years ago at
this point we had already seen Xi
Jinping and Lika Town who at that point
had a realistic stab at the top
leadership already coming out through
housing's time so Victor well let's talk
about that then who do you think are
going to be forming uh the standing
committee the pilot Bureau standing
committee come this October and what
does that say about power and succession
uh so two people almost certainly will
have to step down
um that's Lee Jong Shu and hanjong
because they're above the age of 67. so
according to the established Norm you
know again
67 you can stay 68 you have to retire
so that's seven up eight down which is
like this is kind of informal retirement
threshold uh that's the at the polar
Bureau and above level so at the
ministerial levels except if you're the
general secretary
right here 69. and and yes Secretary
General uh General uh Xi Jinping 69 but
he has no retirement age and again
that's there's no Norm for
the most powerful you know to be fair
there never was especially strong Norms
on Age and and gentlemen flouted it and
so on so forth so
um
basically I think the two people most
likely to join the public real estate
committee are um
uh and I still actually I still like Lee
Chung so it's either going to be Lee
changing to take the other seat
um despite everything and we can talk
about the Chang and Shanghai and so on
so forth but but ding Cho Chang is very
interesting figure for what we discussed
so he is a little bit younger but
nonetheless if Xi Jinping is serving the
full five-year term for the next five
years kind of five years from now he's
gonna be too old to be a successor
because according to the 6768 rule he
can only serve another single term in
the politburo standing committee which
means that he would be quite a bit older
than previous Secretary General who
stepped into that position usually
they're in their late 50s right as
opposed to Mid 60s which will be the
case for ding shushan sort of five years
from now
um
so then the question is who is going to
be the successor I mean I really think
the the oldest they can be is kind of my
age you know chiling ho you know born in
the 70s and in all likelihood I'm
already too old
um the newsletters didn't say well you
don't need that
balling hoe like someone who's born
after the 1980s millennial
so I mean we're really looking at some
very young people here for potential
successor eventually right because as
Bill pointed out I mean she is actually
just just 69 this year
which you know again if you compare to
Joe Biden and these other people Abe and
so and so forth
yeah he's got easily another 15 years if
not longer
um bill I don't want to bring this too
much back to Xi Jinping but I saw a
theory that said that he might set an
expiry date on himself he might say also
have one more term and then um you know
I'll hand over whatever it is obviously
hearing what you guys are saying about
who would want to be a successor in this
kind of system but what do you make of
that theory budget do you think he he
wants to stay on forever
so very specifically recently there's a
Chinese Venture Capital firm that's been
circulating
um a theory or a gas speculation that
CCP will announce that he's only going
to serve one more term a general
secretary Wang Yang will become Premier
um
I don't know you know I think that we
don't know and quite honestly
um why would he if he were to say I'm
willingness or one more term then he's
already basically said I'm a lame duck
which would seem to fly in the face of
his view of how to gain and and
increase and consolidate and exercise
power
um it's possible right I think part of
that Theory comes from this idea that
he's made you know this the belief that
oh he's made a bunch of mistakes so
therefore their pressures within the
system especially among some of the
retired senior cadres
um who want to sort of clip his wings
and
um I can see why that would logically be
the case I'm not sure I can see how that
functionally would happen so
um I I don't honestly I I don't it's
it's certainly possible I mean this is a
problem it's become such a darker
blacker box that the Chinese politics
have than the even wore 10 years ago
that were really all just stuck guessing
and not just us people in Beijing people
all over the system are stuck guessing
um if I could ask Victor a question
though for your two likely candidates
for the standing committee so you don't
think is going to make it
um so there is a scenario if
um Xi Jinping were to force Lee kuchang
out of the public standing committee
again you know he has no reason to do so
you know Lika Chung's only 67. he should
be able to stay for another five years
uh but if there's a move to kind of
force him out then as a kind of a ask
final ask before full retirement Lee
kuchang can ask for hutun Hua to get
into the public bill signing committee
but I mean if I were a she I would do
what you propose which is to get long
Young Who
is can only serve one more term in the
publishing committee to make him
Premiere so that he can serve us just
for five years as to premiere
uh and then promote two people from his
own faction into the politburo standing
committee
um that probably is the best move
because you know for the next five years
if anything goes wrong you know he can
say oh Wong young did it it wasn't my
fault so always good to have someone
like that to blame and then hutun can be
the next you know fall fall guy so to
speak uh at the 21st party Congress that
that would be kind of the best kind of
thing to do and I mean this all is
assumes that they stick to this
a legit age dorm
um yeah and you know there have been
people you know that one of the I forget
the guy's name but he was uh in this
system you know he said a couple years
ago
um at a press conference that basically
this whole this whole seven seven up
eight down is like a is like a folk tale
um and you know that I've certainly been
hearing over the last year and a half
that that they're that there's talk of
lowering it to say 65.
um I don't know I mean when you look at
that there's there's a logic to that I
think when you look at a lot of things
that Xi Jinping has done over the last
several years
um in terms of the various sort of
corruption crackdowns
um you know the both both in the party
the military you know there's a there's
a generation of officials who rose up in
an incredibly corrupt system
and you could see how from Steve's
perspective there might be an advantage
or a desire to basically Lop off a
generation and Skip
um that might be extremely difficult and
would anger a lot of people
um and create a lot of enemies but he
has already created a lot of enemies
I've got so many questions but to start
with Victor um you know we've banded
around quite a few names I'm very
mindful that a lot of listeners won't
know who these people are because who do
you care about in Chinese politics from
the outside other than Xi Jinping um
people might notice the as the premiere
but can we maybe I wonder if the best
way to talk about who these people are
is through you know the factions that
you've kind of hinted at already you
know are there people who are associated
with the more liberal size so maybe for
example one yellow
and then people who are not maybe you
can just maybe could you just overview
the lay of the land for us as far as we
know about this very opaque system I
don't know about liberal or not liberal
um there is the youth league faction so
these were officials who rose up
um partly or holy through the Chinese
Communist Youth League network uh they
were promoted by hujin Tao and some even
say songping so songping is this you
know revolutionary veteran like 103
years old 105.
105 yes
there are even internet rumors calling
for him to come out and sort of save the
country you know and Etc which we can
talk about
um so that Network promoted a number of
senior officials today
which I would say in include Wang Yang I
mean Wang Yang is slightly sort of in
the unhoi branch of it uh who's
currently the chair of the Chinese
people's political consultative
conference but nonetheless in the public
real standing committee and then as Bill
pointed out one of the candidates to be
the next Premier of China we we know
there has to be a new Premiere already
because the kachang himself said that I
will step down from the position of
premiere uh you know uh next year at in
2023.
um the other person who's prominent in
that faction is hutchinhua so hutan Hua
uh was completely in the youth league
Network
um
and then he's currently in Nepal Bureau
as a vice Premier also a candidate for
the next Premier of China and of course
Lee kuchang who's currently Premier
um they they are they tend to be a bit
more pro-market I don't know about
liberal right because Wang Yang has been
in charge of xinjiang and Tibet and
Tibet in the past five years and this
was a brilliant political move by Xi
Jinping because
by the regime's definition
um it's just not going to be pretty when
you're in charge of that xinjiang and
Tibet
and and he put one so could you could
you elaborate that on that because I
mean internationally it's going to be
very very
ugly uh and and will receive a lot and
has received rightly so a lot of
international condemnation sanctions
etc etc
vangyang has been involved in that
that he can there's no portraying him as
the liberal good guy so to speak because
he's been in charge of xinjiang Tibet
it's a brilliant political move by I
mean this is what I've always said Xi
Jinping is a brilliant politician
whatever you say whatever else you say
about him
um yeah so that's on the other side you
have sort of Xi Jinping people in XI
jinping's camp and even there you have
kind of two different Tendencies you
have people who worked with him in
fujian jojiang and Shanghai and there's
a whole bunch of officials like that you
know which I mean are the party
Secretary of Chongqing uh ding Xiao
Xiang that I think is going to get in
public standing committee worked with
him in Shanghai currently his personal
secretary
um the head of the central
Administrative Office Juan Quin Ming
worked with him in in jejun Province
um
uh Tennessee actually his classmate at
Ching Hua University so so did not work
with him
uh and then Lee Chung so we talked about
Lee Chong the Secretary of Shanghai
the other tendency in his faction are
people who did not work with him but are
from North Western China
uh and as you know his family is from
Northwestern China from shanxi Province
uh during the Revolutionary period that
part of China had its own faction the
the shebe the Northwest revolutionary
base area The Descendants and the the
former private secretaries of a lot of
these Elders from that faction
or today some senior officials so Li she
so I finally see to be a very uh
currently the Secretary of Guangdong
Province the head of the Guangdong
Province very interesting guy he was the
personal secretary of a guy who was
friends with XI Jung Shin with XI
jinping's father
um but nonetheless never worked closely
with Xi Jinping himself
and today actually numerically speaking
he has the largest faction so I I do
these kind of calculations of like who's
in who's faction
numerically Xi Jinping today does not
have the largest faction it's actually
Lee she has the largest faction
nonetheless of course publicly speaking
uh she swears his allegiance to Xi
Jinping over and over again
um privately I don't know what he does
to assure she of his loyalty but it must
be something significant because he's
put in charge of Guangdong which of
course is one of the most important
provinces especially economically
speaking in China so that's broadly
speaking you have these two big camps
right now and then you have a lot of
people who are belong to much smaller
factions some of them are getting
promoted we'll see if anyone in that
vein gets promoted into the public
Bureau I think in the public standing
committee almost no chance I mean you
have to either belong to the youth
league or XI jinping's Camp to have a
chance uh in in the public standing
committee but
very systematically try to kneecap the
youth league grouping I mean both you
know you have the downfall of someone
like Ling Chi Hua who was basically
huchintao's like Chief of Staff
um who who you know who ended up he's in
jail for life for corruption
um his kid died in a Ferrari crash with
two naked women in Beijing in 2012
um I mean just goes on and on right but
but I mean after that that sort of
seemed to have opened the door to a real
Crackdown on on bits of the youth league
faction Network you know the youth
league had a university
um I believe I don't know if it was in
Chelsea where it was
um but xinji painting they changed the
name and not only changed the name you
know lots of Chinese institutions will
have a big rock in front where they
chisel in the the name they actually
chiseled off the name right so so it was
it was sort of a very much like not just
we're changing the name we are just
cutting you out right and so
um I I do Wonder like like how many
people who were in that youth fashion
still think there is a protector or a
patron in the system or if many of them
have decided basically
um whether you want to use a term like
Joe on like like you basically go to the
other side or you just basically say
okay there is not a lot of point you
know you saw what happened with sunjun's
high right sunjong Tai who was also
um considered the Leading Light of the
next generation of the youth league
who's now in jail for life
um and so it is a little bit muddier
than I think it was at the sort of in
the who era no no uh I agree with that
and and you do see so if you look at the
statistics
uh people uh in the youth league faction
have been discriminated against when it
comes to promotion Politically Incorrect
so was the head of the youth league
actually so which is a ministerial level
position
very promising uh and then he did
actually go serve as Vice secretary or
governor of some Province and now I
think he's in charge of like the writers
association of China or something like
that
so so he's not he has not been purged
you know so I mean well first of all all
these guys in the usually they've had to
be very careful when it comes to
corruption just absolutely sticking to
the line doing everything by the book
because they know if they deviate at all
they're going to get in big trouble
um but you do see actually some of Wong
Young's people are okay you know they're
not kind of we'll see how many of them
get into the Central Committee but there
are many provincial level people
still who used to work with Huang Yang
and who used to work with uh
um so we'll see how much uh Power these
two officials are able to exercise to
get some of their uh followers into the
the Central Committee I think that will
be a big tell in terms of how much Xi
Jinping has completely Consolidated
power we know he's Consolidated power to
a large extent obviously but whether he
is like you know the only person who can
promote anybody in the system that
remains to be seen
and Victor so then these factions that
you're talking about are they based more
on patronage and networks rather than
policies rather than anything they
believe in
uh yeah exactly so
um well so the way that policy plays a
role is of course you know you look at
Xi Jinping if he prefers a certain
policy like zero covet
then
um people in his faction will carry it
out no matter what
uh people who are not in his faction
also will carry it out no matter what
but behind the scene they might be uh
willing to at least I'm I'm hoping for
the sake of China that they're they're
willing to present some information to
Xi Jinping saying that look this is not
working and we we do have some evidence
of that so we have seen some turns and
policies like we talk about wolf
diplomacy
that has changed a little bit at least I
think I don't know if Bill agrees with
that I mean you know qingang is going
around shaking hands and holding
ambassador to America yeah
the other thing that has changed is the
the housing deleveraging which was a big
policy two years ago obviously now that
they have to turn
uh the housing market is collapsing so
so it's being changed very rapidly
uh so there's still some ability to
change course which is good I guess
well Bill that's the million dollar
question isn't it like how much
resistance does she have in the party
how much of the policy can be laid at
his feet and how much is he is he kind
of controlling and battling off uh
competitors all the time I mean what do
you think
so you know we don't know
um we can observe outcomes
um you know I think that if you look at
like for example Victor just mentioned
the the sort of the the shifting in the
real estate policy
um you know I don't look at that as sort
of the you know quote unquote reformers
whatever that means these days are are
winning as opposed to holy cow this is
collapsing so we need to do something
right a much more of a sort of an
ability to make
um some sort of pragmatic shifts to deal
with reality
um in terms of sort of you know I think
you need to look at a couple of several
threads that have she has I think
executed quite brilliantly the Victor's
earlier point about how she's a
brilliant politician you know you get a
lot of people who say he's not very
bright he has a you know he didn't you
know he graduated he didn't graduate
from middle school blah blah blah you
know he grew up in the cultural
revolution education was
um disrupted and a lot of it was you
know the works of now
um you know a lot of just just not sort
of your your what you can consider to be
sort of a worldly sophisticated
educational background but he's been
absolutely brilliant and ruthless at out
basically outplaying everybody in the
system to get where he is and he's done
that with a few a few ways one I think
if you look at the corruption Crackdown
um which you know he really kicked off
almost immediately after becoming
general secretary in 2012.
um obviously had support from other
people in the system you know look like
retired leaders who said yes you can
move forward on certain things does look
like he went much further
um he's also used the the the body that
investigates corruption in the party the
the
um Central disciplinary inspection
commission
um people say it's a corruption
investigator it's also really the
ideological enforcer so he's used that
body which is effectively like the party
secret police in some ways to really
enforce a
um sort of an ideological shift and and
push through the things around ideology
that um
strengthen his political Foundation
you know look at what he's done in the
security services where you know last
week we had several I think five people
including a vice Minister uh public
security and a former Minister of
Justice who were sentenced to
um several were sentenced to life with
no possibility of parole
um you know he has executed a ongoing
Purge of the Security Services System
you know one it's true they're
incredibly corrupt and you could you
know you could do all sorts of stuff um
if you had knew the right person had
some money
um two though it is very important for
him to clear out anybody who remains
from
other factions or previous leaders who
could potentially threaten she interrupt
his plans
um three in the case of Security
Services you know the the the things
like one of the things that seems to be
going around is that the the vice
Minister who was sentenced last week
um was also wiretapping um
senior leaders including XI which is one
of the big big taboos in um
but it happened under Mao again this is
part of the this is this is history is
repeating which Victor could give us
electron but so my point is he and then
in the military he's done the same where
he's gone through
um and really I think it really kicked
off in 2014 with this meeting in guten
which was basically a rehash of a big
meeting
where he went in and that was his move
to take control of the military and so
he has been very systematic and
effective at
rooting out any potential competitors or
challengers in the main in the in the
security services in the military the
sources of hard power and putting in all
his own people mostly all his own guys
and so that I think also when it go when
you go back to this discussion about
factions you know you look it's like the
youth league people well the youth
league people who do they have in the
security services of the military
who's going to be willing to step up and
challenge XI when the real when the when
the real sources of power on the system
can basically disappear you
directed A wiretapping of sorry to go
back to that point but that does seem
extraordinary like does that show that
there's more opposition to him in the
party than we see on the outside
that is a great question
um and I don't I mean Victor do you have
an opinion I mean I think that
um no no I I always speak historically
so the person who did this for Mao uh
was yangshan Quinn
was the head of jungban of the central
administrative office and he wiretap Mao
because he needed to know everything
that Mao said because of course when you
are the dictator of a country everything
you say become law so he wanted to make
sure that he himself did not deviate
from chairman now at least that's what
he said in his own defense like it's
like I don't want to violate your
dictate because and so in order to do
that I know I need to literally know
everything that you dictate out loud
because your dictates or dictates
um so so that's why he recorded
everything and and I actually think Mao
at some point did give his permissions
like sure just go ahead and record
everything I said I don't really care
but later on that was brought back as
evidence like oh how dare you record me
this is kind of revolutionary Etc and
yamchang Quinn spent you know years in
jail uh before he then he was appointed
to run the military actually during the
dung period so it's very interesting
history today
um
yeah is this Sunni Jin who was doing
this or or so that's the word and then
like one of the guys who was sentenced
last week too was actually in charge of
like the forget the exacto like the
technical Bureau of the ministry of
public security when it was happening
and anyway I moved out to shenshi
um but like classically there's you know
there's the official story of what these
guys did and then there's like the
backstory that goes around that people
talk about well this is what they really
did and we're not we don't know
but it the speculation is always pretty
fascinating
generation that I skipped over by C's
continuation in power then Victor do we
not expect that there will be a lot of
ambitious people in the Communist Party
who thought that they would have their
Chance by the time it got to them and
are now being looked over are they a
dangerous thing to be considering
um well you know many of these people
have been promoted into the public
Bureau already so you know where there
is quite a bit of power already and you
know it's a very pyramidal system
uh so people like
are also slightly younger born I think
62 63.
uh these are officials who you know
definitely would have had a chance to
get into the public real estate
committee and potentially even serving
as the Secretary General but because of
uh Xi Jinping staying because of the
lack of generational turnover in general
um many of these people are going to say
in the public Bureau which which I would
say is not such a terrible outcome uh
and you begin to see this kind of
happening in the late Soviet period
where you know these a lot of these
people they're in the politburo they
just come to run the policy area that
they're in charge of as a fiefdom you
know and then they they you know
obviously engage in corruption
today is there corruption I think it's a
lot less visible but of course it still
happens of course there is of course
there is of course there is you know all
these companies are listing you know why
do you think they're like five stock
markets in China
it's like all these political forces
behind the scenes trying to get their
own startup listed so they can
make money basically Bill knows a lot
more about that bill can tell us all
about how that all works well bill I
found you a newsletter I mean I always
find it valuable I found it particularly
valuable in following the semiconductor
Industries Crackdown because you know
that's one of the key industries that
the government has been directing from
the centers being billions of dollars
poured into it and a lot of anti-graft
measures going on in there
yeah so a couple things that I've heard
and again take these as as sort of
Grapevine but um from people who are
usually pretty reliable is is that
they're you know part of it I think has
been reported there was a review of this
whole semiconductor the big fund um over
the summer
um and uh lioha the current Vice career
was running the review
and
the the revalization came out that they
were not nearly as advanced as they had
been led to believe in terms of because
it's all about breaking through the
various uh technology bottlenecks that
the uh effective the U.S controls and
sanctions or kensanction China over
um and so that led to there have been an
auto ongoing to um that led to this the
Spate of publicized arrests I'm hearing
that there are lots more people who are
under investigation
um people in the industry academics
um and you know being they talked about
it I think in a recent
um forget it was a popular meeting or a
study session where it talked about sort
of a new setting up a new system a
national system for sort of big
scientific achievements I think what
you're going to see and this goes back
to the sort of will they move towards
more reform or not I think you're going
to see on the semiconductors more of an
approach to like the Space Program where
they're going to actually put somebody
with potentially experience in the space
Department maybe for the military in
charge of this National level effort to
make breakthroughs in course
semiconductor Technologies but that is
one where there was just too much money
that there was it's a big priority so
here's checks for hundreds of billions
of MMB the people running the funds are
underpaid compared to the people making
who have companies that are getting
invested in and it's really easy to set
up companies with relatives and friends
and funnel some of the money through and
get a percentage
it's still too easy and too tempting
yeah absolutely well I want to talk
about policy as well because
um we've already mentioned xeracovid in
passing in in this conversation but
Victor I mean the National Party
Congress is also an opportunity where
you know they reviewed the last five
years they look ahead to the next five
years so on and so forth
um will we see any big policy changes
for example will we see a loosening of
zero covered or
um remarketization or um whatever it is
what do you think
uh I don't see any huge turn
um there will be some modification uh
but not with covet I mean you know the
success of zero covet was written in the
resolution on history in late 2021
it is a huge victory of the Chinese
Communist party and of Xi Jinping
himself so that policy cannot change uh
it can be modified it can be made into a
bit more flexible but I think that's
going to happen sort of at the state
Council level it's really not going to
be
I think officially the political work
report will still say that zero covet is
the correct policy in general we must
continue to pursue it etc etc where I
think um there could be some um more
significant changes is a focus on
economic growth I mean so economic
growth really is not doing very well in
China now consumption is very weak
um you know yet again you're seeing more
Chinese economists talking about like
you know consumption is very weak in
China we have to boost it in these
various ways uh there have been some
measures rolled out but just drips and
drafts nothing that will make any
significant difference
so hopefully something more meaningful
is going to get rolled out with regards
to huko and then giving I mean I am
hopeful although I keep on hoping it
never comes to pass I'm hopeful that for
migrant workers you know remember China
still has like two 300 million wagon
workers who basically live in the cities
but they're they're not entire class
citizens they're second-class citizens
and they're second-class citizens and
that's where the central government
needs to spend an enormous amount of
money to boost the welfare and Social
Services for those people
uh and ironically that's something that
the the Communist party has refused to
do for decades and decades I mean to to
all your
fans out there who who love uh you know
the party in communism
I wish the party would behave more like
a Communist party I think that would be
wonderful but it hasn't I would be
intrigued to know how many listeners are
actually fans of the party enough
communism along Victor can I jump in or
or of course yeah what I was going to
say is along that along Victor's point
you know when you look back at the
announcement from the I think it was the
August popular meeting about the dates
for the um for the party Congress and
then sort of the broadly speaking what's
going to be in it
um one was a revision of the
Constitution they don't say what
um two other points of note though were
one was they specifically say that
they're gonna talk about common
Prosperity right which is this term that
has been around the party for a very
long time which came back sort of with
it of engines last year or two years ago
um and has since freaked out a lot of
investors both foreign and domestic in
China and
we don't really know exactly what that
means there's a pilot underway in
jojiang Province but it it is not um
there have been some hope earlier this
year I think among investors at least
that maybe they had de-emphasized it
because of all the economic growth
problems
um the fact that it's listed in the
announcement of the party Congress as
it's one of the key themes is probably
means that it it's going to come back in
a big way it may include some of the
stuff Victor is talking about which is
actual
um acting a little more communist in
terms of things like the the who calling
migrant workers
um we don't know but that is I think
going to be one of the you know one of
the a lot of the focus has been oh who's
up Who's down you know is she going to
get these titles but there is going to
be I think some real substance coming
out of that the other thing that's not
economic related but it is very much I
think matters for the politics relations
Is that announcement of the party
Congress very specifically mentioned
stuff around history and history is one
of the big thrusts of cgping in terms of
re of of re of controlling his history
and reshaping history about China and
what happened to China and China's place
in the world and that depending how it
goes could be
um
cause a lot of frictions
um
internationally and also could lead to
some I think some potential stress
inside China on a political perspective
build that in your newsletter about kind
of state sanctioned revisiting of the
Ming Dynasty and whether or not it was a
good thing that during that time you
know China closed up to the world and
actually saying yeah actually and like
received wisdom it was a good thing for
China to have closed a bit more
that was very uh that was a essay came
out over the summer
um basically a very revisionist essay
saying that the the sort of China's
closed approach to the world in Imperial
in the last two dynasties was actually
um
not bad and the sort of the top level is
it like had its advantages right and it
was written by
um a journal that's affiliated with a
new Institute that was set up I think in
2019 under the Chinese Academy of social
sciences by somebody who is known to
have a sort of had a relationship with
Xi Jinping
um seeing as quite leftist uh and it
freaked a lot of people out inside China
because it was a
um sort of in the in the context of
what's going on with with Dynamics here
at covet and the way China has closed
itself off this was seen as an
intellectual historical justification
for a much
um a much more sort of closed off
isolationless policy that could also be
sort of married to this idea that the
you know the the leadership started
pushing this idea of a dural circulation
strategy which was really sort of
focused more on the domestic Market yes
we'll use the foreigners for Capital and
stuff we need but we're gonna We're Not
Gonna you know we're gonna screen out a
lot more stuff in terms of culture and
ideas and that very much is is one one
of the you know some of the key themes
of the Sierra so far and so this piece
again freaked out a lot of people you've
had some academics sort of come out and
say this is a bad idea
um we're sort of left wondering now when
this institute was founded into or was
established in the 19 cgp wrote a letter
to it commending it you know
congratulations for its its creation
which again leads people to think well
is this sort of she really believes this
or is this some sort of balancing among
like leftist conservative ideas and not
so much conservative before the party
Congress we don't know but it's not a um
it's not an encouraging sign and and
again the the way when I say that I'm
not talking about like performed
reserves I'm talking about you people
inside China who were very freaked out
by this because of what it could
potentially pretend
yeah I I have to agree from but you know
you have to look at things from the
party's perspective you know what
happened in the past two and a half
years
since covet uh in terms of China's
exchanges with the rest of the world has
been perfectly fine yeah
trade continue in fact China ran the
largest Trade Surplus it had ever ran
in 2020 and 2021 this year maybe a
little bit smaller but mainly because
you know Europe uh consumption in Europe
has sort of fallen off
um at the same time there's a very high
barrier to entry for foreigners going to
China
no big deal they're all spies anyway
there is a very high barrier for Chinese
people to leave China because of zero
covet also not a big deal because you
know these people are just going to go
and buy expensive purses in France we
don't need that right and and see how
the rest of the world is reopened
yeah exactly and you're right no you're
it's a feature not a bug
yeah I think Victor that's particularly
interesting because it's so easy to
think she has completely screwed this
one up you know look at zero cover look
at the fact that China is still living
under repeated lockdowns look at the
economy look at the choking of your home
of your homegrown Silicon Valley
um look at the closing of the Chinese
mind when it comes to kind of
psychologically how you think about
foreigners and International Community
but Victor you're pointing out actually
that people in the party and people from
the participle perspective actually
think that he's done okay if not
actively good
well look uh um some of the tragedies
that unfolded in Shanghai I'm sure
privately even party insiders thought
that that was not ideal
uh but I think for them it was more of a
kind of a logistics issues than than the
problem with the overall yeah policy of
zero covet I think there's still even
not just in the party but at the popular
level there still is a lot of support
for zero covet actually
and and you have to remember you know
all these videos that you see like
people getting angry they're fighting
with the police and so and so forth
those are very few cases in the midst of
like an enormous scale of rolling
lockdowns I mean there are dozens and
dozens of cities at any given time which
are under lockdown in China Roy Lee you
know on the borders of Burma has been in
lockdown continuously for you know two
years you know whatever it is
you don't see a big Riot there and in
fact in really I mean I think Bloomberg
or somebody did a really excellent
series of pieces on it recently it's
super Draconian I mean people have been
in basically incarcerated in their homes
continuously for years
[Music]
um
and and so I think this policy can
continue I think it's terrible for
China's economy actually because and
also for the population right I mean if
you want the population to grow there
has to be family formation
if people can't leave their Apartments
how can you possibly have family
formation I mean you can't and you're
also breaking up some families
presumably yeah breaking up family well
okay some families are having more
babies whatever but uh but at least on
the margin you can't have yeah a family
formation when if this continues
um so there are there are high high
price to be paid in the medium term but
in the short term I think a lot of
people in the party think that's fine
final words otherwise I'm thinking I'm
going to wrap up there I've taken up so
much of your time already
read Victor's book it's great
brilliant Victor's Burke Victor can you
plug your book first yes uh my book is
called coalitions of the week Elite
politics in China from Mao stratagem to
the rise of she you can get it on Amazon
or if you order from the Cambridge
University press website I think that
discount code is uh
s-h-i-h-2022 that should give you a 20
discount lovely thank you so so much
both thank you Bill and thank you Victor
thanks for listening Chinese Whispers is
a podcast brought to you by The
Spectator and if you'd like to listen to
more just search Chinese Whispers
wherever you get your podcast from and
if you like what we do here you might be
interested in the Chinese Whispers
newsletter that I will be launching in
the near future sign up for free at
spectator.co.uk forward slash Whispers
And you'll be getting regular updates
from me on the most interesting
political and cultural news from China
as well as of course a smattering of
History that's spectator.co.uk forward
slash Whispers
foreign
[Music]